Hello Freak bitches.
Everyone knows that the two
party system is kind of stupid,
but everyone seems to think that any other
party other than the two party system
is unrealistic or any other party,
like a Libertarian Green party
somewhere along anything independent is
unrealistic.
Well,
I'm,
I'm back to right now 50% of all people
that are registering to vote or are
registering is independent.
Statistically,
right now,
43% of America is independent,
but new registrations,
50%.
So I don't,
uh,
I don't know as the,
as people do identify
with the two parties,
the rigged game of the system is,
is that we're only
presented with two choices.
And that really starts with
just being in the polls.
Look right now,
if Mickey Mouse,
where the third name in any poll,
Mickey would be pulling it
30% but Mickey's not on the
ballot in all 50 states.
And if I'm the libertarian nominee and I
hope to be the libertarian nominee that
happens next weekend,
um,
I'm going to be the only other candidate
on the ballot in all 50 states.
So polling,
I,
I just want to be in the polls.
There is no way a third party wins
without being in the presidential debates.
That's just not going to happen.
A Superbowl of politics to get
in the presidential debates,
you have to be at 15% in the polls,
Joe.
The rig game is,
is that if you're not in the polls,
there's no way that you can pull at 15%,
but it has to be a consistent polling.
Um,
starting now,
I was in the first national poll
that I've been in a month ago.
I haven't been in a national poll since,
but in a month,
a month ago,
I was at 11% against Hillary and Trump.
And was this all established back when
Ross Perot sort of shook up the political
establishment because that there was a
lower percentage required to get involved
in debates before that actually sent?
Well,
actually there was no percentage
points prior to Ross Perot.
That was something that got
established after Ross Perot.
And what,
what is amazing to me is Ross Perot
after having gotten 19% of the general
election vote the first time.
The second time he ran,
they did not allow him in
the presidential debates,
which is just,
I mean,
that's the rigged nature of the game.
The rig nature of the game is,
is come this fall.
If my name does not appear
in another single pole,
the presidential debate commission,
we'll say a Gary Johnson.
He just didn't pull high enough.
What they've,
what they won't say is that he wasn't
in the polls and the commission for
presidential debates is a
privately funded institution.
Private Democrats and Republicans were
suing the presidential debate commission.
Also,
we think that it's a antitrust,
we think that,
uh,
not think it's Democrats and Republicans
and they collude with one another to
exclude else.
Bruce Fein is suing the
presidential debate commission.
Bruce finds claim to fame is that
he brought Nixon down in Watergate,
but in the next sentence,
he will tell you that the biggest thing
he's ever done in his life is suing the
presidential debate commission because
this has the opportunity of changing
politics in America.
I mean,
this is really at the
heart of this rig game.
You can't win the presidency if you're
not in the super bowl of politics.
We've,
we figured the dollar value alone of
being in the presidential debates is
several hundred million dollars.
Just think of the Super Bowl and the
ads that sell during the super bowl.
And imagine being a,
having second biggest audience.
You don't have like 75 million people for,
you know,
90 minutes,
two hours.
That's a couple of hundred million
dollars worth of advertising.
Yeah.
That is the show.
And if you're not in the show,
people don't consider your vote.
Like they think of,
even if you have 50% of these people
that are registering and saying they're
independent,
what they're really saying is they're
not committing to a left or a right.
They're not committing to
a democratic or Republican,
but are they gonna vote independent?
That's a lot of people.
They have this idea that
if you vote independent,
you're throwing away your vote.
That's,
that is a stigma that has to be overcome.
Right?
No,
no,
no.
I,
I agree,
but,
but for those people that they do vote
right and they end up voting on the basis
of the lesser of two evils.
But since they're registering to vote
and they're registering to vote as
independent,
they end up at the polls.
I mean,
for the most part,
most,
most people don't even go to the poll.
Most people don't even vote.
Yeah,
it's,
is there a way to fix it?
Do you think that there's a way to maybe
somehow or another allow people to vote
online and change the way it's set up?
Now?
We don't have to physically
go to a location.
You don't have to sign
up physically in a place.
So you can actually just do it from
your computer the same way we bank.
That has to be the future.
Um,
that does not exist now,
but that has to be the future.
And from a legislative standpoint,
meaning,
okay,
you're president of the United
States or governor of New Mexico,
you could sign legislation that,
um,
and,
and these are the things
that are going to happen.
It's going to be easier
and easier to vote.
And that's what should be the case.
Be the case if the system
isn't totally Rick.
Cause the problem is people like Hillary,
um,
the people that are
longtime establish them,
people that have been a
part of politics forever,
the last thing they want to do is turn
over the reins to the Internet because
she's had what did what,
how much they send.
They say they're spending spending over
a million dollars just to combat online
trolls just to go on reddit
and forums and correct people.
Yes.
And I would,
I would be surprised if
the number was that low.
Yeah.
I would be surprised too.
I think,
uh,
they're probably being pretty
conservative about that.
But the idea is that the internet
doesn't like the establishment.
They know that there's a
real problem with the system,
the system in place as is.
And the Internet,
when I say the Internet and of the,
the broad stroke that you're painting is
obviously young people who are a little
bit more aware of how screwy this whole
system that they're sort of born into
is.
And that the people that are
in charge don't want change.
They want to keep it at two party system.
They want to keep this silly white hat,
black hat,
goofy game going on forever
and keep control of the power
right on.
And this,
but this cycle for the
first time in my lifetime,
this might change.
I mean this because of just how
polarizing the two of them are.
Yeah,
and I think Bernie Sanders is what a lot
of people think of as the alternative
right now.
Mainstream alternative.
He stands pretty far out
there from the other guys.
So have you seen the
website I side with.com no,
I haven't.
You gotta write it down.
You've got to take,
take this political quiz I
side and everybody listening
take this political quiz
I side with.com it's about 60 questions.
It's really easy.
You don't have to,
you know know you.
You don't have to sign up on the website,
but you take this quiz and at the end
of the quiz you get paired up with a
presidential candidate most
in line with your views.
It just makes real sense.
I think everybody should take the
quiz and whoever you line up with,
um,
I think you should knock yourself
out supporting that person.
Well,
for me,
taking the I side with quiz,
amazingly,
the next politician that I aligned with
outside of the libertarians that are
running for president is Bernie Sanders.
Um,
I aligned with Bernie
Sanders 73% of what he says.
Now,
when it comes to economics,
we come to a t in the road,
uh,
when it comes to the socialism versus,
um,
you know,
being an entrepreneur when it comes to
big government versus small government,
we come to that t in the road.
But,
uh,
on the issues of legalizing marijuana,
same sex marriage,
a woman's right to choose,
hey,
let's stop with these
military interventions.
This is just,
this is just crazy.
We're in line.
So,
um,
I,
I pushed this website because,
um,
it should work the other way around.
Okay.
I side with Bernie most of the time,
but oh my gosh,
the libertarian candidate,
Gary Johnson,
I side with next in line.
And I do believe that,
um,
Bernie is not going to get the nomination.
I don't think that's going to happen.
And where do all those voters go?
Where does 50% of Republicans go that
really are at the end of the day and was
socially tolerant and
fiscally conservative.
And I think that is the
majority of Republican voters,
but a,
they'd been co opted by the social
conservatives that have an agenda that I
think is really a turnoff
to most of America.
And it's okay to be a social conservative.
There's nothing wrong with
being a social conservative,
but if you,
if you equate,
if you make that public policy,
if you pass laws regarding
social conservatism,
you end up putting people in
jail for personal choices.
And we do have the highest incarceration
rate of any country in the world.
And I think that starts with the drug war.
The word conservative is interesting too,
when you apply it to social issues
like social conservativism cause
conservatives really want the original
conservatives were stay out of my
business.
I'll stay out of yours.
So social conservative really wouldn't
apply to like things along the lines of
gay marriage or same sex
unions or anything along those.
You would,
you'd say,
we'll leave those people alone.
That would be the conservative approach.
The government should stay
out of those people's lives.
Right.
Well,
it started out as classical liberal,
classical liberal is being fiscally
conservative and socially liberal,
which got co-opted.
I mean,
that,
that used to be what a
conservative was co opted.
And,
um,
like I said,
I think we're a little bit of both.
You,
you've heard the old adage that if
in college you weren't a Democrat,
you didn't have a heart,
and if a,
as an adult,
you weren't a Republican,
you didn't have a brain.
Well,
I think we've got both.
All of us have gotten
both of those things.
Yeah.
It's,
it's just real polarizing
to have only two choices.
Well,
and it's,
and it's so polarizing because the,
those issues,
um,
at the,
at the end of the day,
um,
why can't Democrats and Republicans
come together on some very common sense
issues that would move
the country forward.
Okay.